hello and welcome to lab week
thank you lab roots for giving sativa
the opportunity to present
my name is donald green i am a field
application specialist for saitiva
and today i will be discussing our new
direct rtq pcr kit
the kit can be broken into two parts the
aic mix which is the part that makes it
extraction free
and the rtq pcr chemistry which is also
lyell stable
i'll get into more of that later on in
the discussion
but please i hope you enjoy the content
and i look forward to you reaching out
with questions
before we jump head first into the kit i
will discuss a few other topics
the first one the pcr and rtpcr market
polymerase chain reaction or pcr is one
of the major advances in the field of
molecular biology
used in diagnostic and research
laboratories the world over
to generate really sufficient quantities
of dna to be tested
the global reach of digital pcr and qpcr
has been expected to grow by leaps and
bounds
the increase is really due to the
availability
and higher demand for different kinds of
master mixes for the technology
government funding to the diagnostic and
life science sector and really an
evolution of pcr variants
that have led to an increased
application in the diagnosis of
infectious diseases
the next question would be why reverse
transcription quantitative pcr
or rtq pcr we use rtqpcr
to amplify a transcribed cdna from rna
into multiple copies
it's quantitative which means it
measures dna concentration in real time
and it typically has a one-step process
or two-step
process in the one-step process we use
it for
large samples to really reduce chances
of the contamination process
in the process the two-step process is
preferred when sample
is scarce or multiple sampling may be
required from one sample
so if we take a look at where rtq pcr is
widely used
we can see that it's been widely used to
calculate rna expression
levels within tissue diagnose genetic
disorders such as muscular dystrophy
or diagnose diseases certain viruses
which have
rna genomes such as you guessed it
coven 19 hiv htv
etc
so next we're going to take a look at
the global market for pcr technology by
type focusing in on the rt pcr market
share
the market share has been around 13.7
percent
for the past few years and it was
expected to grow
on average at around 5.2 percent between
the forecast period
which was 2016 through 2021. as you can
imagine that number's probably been
blown
out of the water currently but i haven't
seen the updated numbers but as you can
imagine everyone is really using
rt pcr and qpcr for the coven 19
pandemic
but previous to the pandemic why was
this technology expected to continue to
grow
well the increase of testing viral
pathogenic agents
had already started um the technology
also
obviously gives us the ability to
convert rna into dna
which is very useful in the diagnosis of
infectious diseases
ie cova 19 and the sensitivity
the accuracy and the reproducibility
which
was was being processed and it's been
gained
severe importance in the past decade
just due to its capacity for
making complementary dna
one of the last things i'd just like to
review is really the difference between
extraction versus direct applications
so if we take a look at the application
area nucleic acid amplification testing
is preferred over traditional culture
techniques due to
higher sensitivity and speed is used
very widely and apply market testing
to detect infectious diseases and
metagenomics
and i'm sure you can list out some of
your own
what are some of the challenges and
opportunities associated with just doing
rna extraction
typically some of the challenges in rna
extraction include the barrier to scale
up the testing
in the molecular pathology lab because
of lengthy extraction steps because of
complex protocols
because of the number of reagents
required because of the cost
the expertise needed with hands-on and
then the compromise sensitivity with
some of the older methods
where extraction-free methods come into
play and give you opportunities
we they can be used as a screening tool
in high throughput and scale-up setup
where time to result is critical they
reduce the extraction kit bottlenecks
particularly
which have been particularly prevalent
with the current night curve 19 pandemic
and they provide a simpler more cost
effective protocol
as well as eliminate cross-contamination
risks during extraction setup
and what we can say is the nucleic acid
yield is usually not as variable as it
is with the extraction
process
so if we take a look just an overall
high level viewpoint of traditional
extraction versus
our direct rtq pcr approaches
traditional extraction is still great
right it's the gold standard and
traditional method gives you high levels
of purity
you can use the aliquots later for
different tests save the rest
potential for larger samples and gives
you
very high levels of concentration
however for the direct chemistry
if you're looking for a quick tit
or rapid turnaround time it gives you a
rapid protocol
fewer steps less time less hands-on time
which means less contamination potential
very cost effective
convenient one vial containing all the
critical components for the license
and handle small samples with very good
sensitivity
thank you very much for listening to all
the background information giving us a
greater foothold on
understanding the purpose for our rtq
pcr chemistry and our direct rt
qpcr kits
so what is the cytiva direct rtq pcr kit
our kit can be split into really two
main components we have
our aic mix which is our anti-inhibitor
complex mix
which really protects your rna that's
the secret sauce if you will and then
our master mix and reconstitution
buffers
which is basically our qpcr master mix
dried down into a
live fly's cake and then our
reconstitution buffer
you combine both of those and you get
our direct
rtq pcr kit which gives you the
robust extraction-free chemistry that
has been optimized for a one-step
detection of rna really optimized
towards
the detection of kovit
continuing on in the vein of what is the
sativa direct rtq pcr kit
what we want you to really take heed to
is this kit allows a user to really lyse
the sample
basically by heat with the aic mix
stabilizing the rna
against nucleases and pcr inhibitors
just an aliquot of the lysate is needed
you can add it directly into your
rtqpcr master mix providing a highly
sensitive
specific amplification and detection of
rna from various sample material
and very in less time when i say less
time if we go over and look at the
figure to the right you will see if
you're taking
from step one of the gray boxes you
collect your sample
then you go into rna extraction say rna
extraction is approximately 60 minutes
because that's really going to depend on
the kit
it's going to depend on the skill of the
person performing
using the kit and it's going to can
really depend on you know a
few other factors how far things are
apart in the lab
if you come down to the direct rtpcr
kit you will see that we
taking your collection of your sample
goes directly into your aic mix
we say approximately 10 minutes but it's
5 to 10 minutes
and what you can see is the amount of
time you save
from the green box and the gray box
during the what we would call the
extraction free versus the rna
extraction
that's where you really get your time
savings you can imagine if you're doing
this extraction 10 times a week just
look at the amount of time you would
save
over the course of the week
so i really want to hammer this home to
you very in a very feature benefit
setup so one of the features again
you lice the sample by heat you put your
sample directly into
the aic mix the asc mix is a very
good stabilizer of the rna you
heat it for five minutes and then you
take an aliquot
of that lysate and directly into the qrt
master mix
so it's a very streamlined easy workflow
time and cost savings
minimal handling handling issues and
minimal sample loss
our kit includes all the critical
reagents
for sample to result workflow there's a
stabilized master mix and they
available in cake or bead format which
really provides you
a very ease of use
convenience very automatable some of the
benefits that we'll discuss
in the in the data down below you will
see that
with our kit you actually have a higher
tolerance to transport media
which allows you to be more capable of
detecting
low viral loads even when the sample
volume
the sample transport media volume
reaches around 45 percent
of the final reaction volume and you
also get increased rna stability of the
sample
and we've been shown to detect cova-19
particles down to approximately 10
copies per
reaction so the benefit there is the
kit is very robust sensitive and very
reproducible
lastly the flexibility of the kit it
works with a wide range of
sample types suave cells blood and body
fluids
compatible with both real-time and
endpoint rt-pcr
compatible with the wide ranges of
transport media
and suitable for manual and automated
protocols
really quickly before we got go into the
performance data i want to
give some background into our actual
genomics portfolio
it's very relevant with a wide variety
of different customer
market space future molecular diagnostic
applications
fits in with qpcr ngs and other types of
nucleic acid testing
we have some great dna isolation kits
our sarah extractor cell free
kit which minimizes genomic dna our cell
extracted genomic dna kit which
minimizes
rna within your sample our sara
extractor virus pathogen kit
which has been used very very well
with the covet 19 pandemic is really
designed for that
and then we have our extraction free
chemistry which fits
right in here
we also have our amplification
chemistries if you have particular
amplification issues with
maybe a single cell with genomify if you
if you want to use templify which is for
circular dna
genomifies for linear dna and then we
have some
size selection and pcr cleanup reagents
what we call our ceramic select
which really fits directly into your
workflow and gives you one option
for a one beat option for pcr cleanup
and size selection
if you want to know any additional
information about any of these products
please don't hesitate to reach out to me
and now we will get into
the performance data
jumping directly into our rna detection
which is
exactly what what we need to discuss
right this these are the
the performance data that you need to
see just a
bit of the background we'll have a bar
plot and then we'll have a standard pair
of plot on your right bar plot on your
left
in the bar plot you'll see the primer
set n1
targeting the engine of cover 19
based on cdc suggestions obviously
the plot shows the results combined from
three independent experiments
with technical replicas run each time
the positive control primers are
targeting the
human rna p gene which i'm sure you're
very familiar with
we are also used a plasma template
control
which really is a plasmid coding for the
same artificial sequence contained in
the
viral particles and then we did an
artificial viral containing a portion of
the cova 19
viral genome and that last portion
and what you can see here is we wanted
you to see the difference
in the protective capabilities of our
aic mix versus no aic mix
you can see in the first bar the far
left
we ran the samples without any asc mix
for the n1
primer set as well as the rna sp
you can see without any aic mix there
was no protection
so there were no results basically as a
failed experiment
simply put putting it with the aic mix
for both the n1
and the rnasp you will see that the
experiment passed
based on the ct value of around 35 or so
and rnhp relatively low because it comes
up with
basically anything if you've used it
before it's very very robust we all know
that
and then again we tested it with some
artificial um
primer sets as well plasma template
control and the
artificial in one virus
and you can still see with the aic mix
we still get great results
we actually obtain results from just
five minutes
sample right into the aic mix
so the next thing i want you to take a
look is to your right
you will see the standard curve really
demonstrating the
linear and sensitive detection of viral
rna
across a wide range of viral loads
if you take a look at the
10 viral particles per reaction
you'll see the n1 will still detect it
around the same ct value correct then
you take a look at the hundred viral
particle reactions
it was detected a thousand of course it
was detected ten thousand and so forth
the numbers on the right are not
surprising the numbers
all the way to the left the ten viral
particles per reaction
really shows the sensitivity of our kit
why is this important you guys well as
with covert 19
you may not have a ton of virus immune
system so if you're able to detect down
to
very small amount of copies
in the sample you can still trigger a
a response that oh this person has covet
19. that's very very important
and then if you take a look at the rnsp
we just wanted to keep that in there to
let you know that
the rnap worked fine in the experiment
so there's nothing screwy going on
the next discussion we're going to have
that i mentioned earlier is the
tolerance to transport medium
this particular case we are using
nasopharyngeal samples from cover 19
negative donors
and we spiked them with a heat
inactivated cover 19 viral particles
so if you take a look here and this was
very surprising for us right this wasn't
something we
started out with the expection
expectation that it was going to happen
but if you take a look
the sativa direct rt qpcr
chemistry exhibits very high tolerance
to transport media compared to some of
the others on the market
some of the others on the market really
tap out at around 25
or 30 percent of the transport media
being in the final reaction volume but
what we can say is that with our
detection we can get we can get up to
45 of the final volume of the transport
media
and we still see benefit we still see
results
if you think about it this can be very
again very beneficial
when testing borderline negative or
positive samples you're essentially
doubling the sample volume tested
without affecting the assay sensitivity
so just going over to the bar graph
you'll see
that we tested at 25 and we tested at 45
for n1 n2 and then rnasp
and you can see the results speak for
themselves
they're are basically the same um so
this is this is a really great finding
for us right and many of our customers
really appreciate it because they can
put in
again more of the transport volume which
increases the probability that they
actually have more of the virus
on board to run through to run their
sample with
so the next experiment we wanted to
carry out with with the kit
was using different transport media
obviously with the amount of people
going into
trying to test kova 19 transport meteors
were
pretty wide widely unavailable
the cdc actually put out a recommended
alternative collection
media that can be prepared very very
locally
including pbs saline and then the more
widely used standard universal
viral transport media suitable for cell
culture
what we did is the graph to the left
shows you that the sativa direct rt
qpcr chemistry allows the detection of
viral load
in a wide dynamic range really
irrespective of the transport media it's
used in
again we looked at pbs saline and then
just a
standard universal transport media for
cell culture growth
and using positive nasopharyngeal swabs
we were still able to see
the no template control there was
nothing there
and then the dilution factor of ten
thousand one thousand
one hundred
one of the last experiments we did was
really just to
show that this doesn't just work with
cover 19 which is where the kit was
really birthed out of
but it can be compatible with other
viral particles so we took a look at
ebola
and as similar as we did previously we
did a noise no aic mix
with an aic mix and you can see the
results
that even under challenging conditions
really defined by
mesopharyngeal sample we could detect
ebola viral particles thank you for
listening to all the data i'm sure it
was very exciting and i hope you guys
really appreciate it last thing we're
going to do is take you through a quick
summary
of the kit kind of hit some frequently
asked questions and some of the top tips
that we have available currently
taking a look at this quick summary
slide what we're going to say is the
sativa direct rtq pcr kit enables
a one step extraction free procedure
using nucleic acid
amplification testing technology it
addresses a few needs here right it
addresses the need for rapid and
high-throughput rna detection
provides a very sensitive and robust
reproducibility reproducible solution
with highlighted
highlighted information such as
increased tolerance of up to 45 percent
of the universal transport media
increased rna stability within the
sample and
again we specifically developed this kid
out of the need for cover 19
and we can show pretty successfully that
we can detect cover 19 particles
down to approximately 10 copies per
reaction
this full kit includes all the critical
reagents
really allowing kind of a sample to or
increasing the speed of sample to result
workflow
works with a dynamic range of sample
types swabs cells body fluids and it's
pretty easy to set up for manual or
animate automated protocols
so one of the things i wanted to take
you through as i mentioned is the
frequently asked questions about the kit
and hopefully we can clear up some of
those for you
can the direct rtq pcr kit be used with
any universal transport media
the answer is yes however we
do have issues with utms containing
license reagents already
right if the aic mix is really helping
you lice based on heat
we don't need to like we don't need the
sample already lice so
any utms that contain license reagents
such as
sds or guanidinium should be out of the
out of the picture they don't work
really well with aic mix
can i use other sample volumes other
than the ones recommended
we recommend 5 microliters of universal
transport media
input volume as a guide however based on
the data we've shown you previously
the sample can be further optimized with
the addition of
the universal transport media volumes
being increased
being between three microliters and 8.5
is what we've been seeing kind of in our
labs
as long as you're keeping the aic mix in
the constant six
that's this is what we encourage
what sample volume should be used for
the rt qpcr mix we recommend a total of
11 microliters of lysate
meaning the five microliters of sample
plus six microliters of aic to be added
to the rtqpcr master mix to get a final
reaction volume of around 20 microliters
my starting sample is old and could be
degraded what can i do
due to the unstable nature of rna we
recommend working with fresh samples
where possible and store samples in utm
as recommended by the collection
ii manufacturer can i use the aic mix to
inactivate the virus
sativa has not validated the efficacy of
viral inactivation
at aic within the aic at 70 marker
70 degrees incubation time for five
minutes
lab optimizing to use our formulation
will need to do
this need to satisfy themselves that
they have sufficient approvals to work
with infectious agents
using our kids can i scale up volumes
recommended
as it is difficult to pipette smaller
volumes
we understand that however the accurate
pipetting of the smaller volumes is
recommended
to really mitigate issues when working
with samples with higher viscosity
the aic mix is not working properly what
should i do
it should be considered that the
efficacy of the sativa aic mix always
depends
on the sample matrix or
the type of swab solution and the rt
qpcr kit to which it was used
the top tips that we have seen with
customers
testing our kit using our kit using the
aic mix
we recommend using the we recommend
mixing the axi mix before use
and then in the aspiration step as inten
as it tends to settle
if left to stand for long periods of
time five ten minutes fifteen minutes
post mixing and on on ice
when inhibition is observed with the
direct rtq pcr kit we recommend
adjusting and or reducing the sample
volume added to the
to the reaction some rtq pcr master
mixes
are not robust enough to handle the
inhibitory agents present
in our present in the lysate or present
in the aicmix plus sample
so if you are just using the aic mix
alone with your
in-house rtq pcr
and you're not really getting good
results where inhibition is suspected
or the reaction of efficiency is poor we
recommend comparing
the sample with our rtq pcr kit
as obviously the aic mix has been
optimized
for covin and optimized for using with
our
rtq pcr kit
keep in mind the sativa direct rtq pcr
kit is not certified
or ce ivd marked but it can be validated
by labs looking for a rapid solution for
routine testing a viral
sample so that validation you can do the
validation in your lab and
do your own develop ldt sativa again has
not validated the efficacy of viral
inter in it
activation with aic mix at 70 degrees
incubation for five minutes again labs
optimizing
to use our formulation would need to
satisfy themselves that they have
sufficiently
approvals to work with infections agents
create
infectious agents using our kit
there is a risk of contamination due to
condensation on the pcr plate
we always recommend sealing after
opening for the addition of the pcr
reagent we recommend using uh
just a basically heat sealer which i
know everyone is familiar with
so just really wanted to do a quick
breakdown of the products and
specifications and
kind of draw into some important points
here the
if we take a look at the full direct rt
qpcr kit
what you will have is the aic mix with
our
qpcr kit or chemistry
and we actually offer them separately
we've had customers that really
wanted to just have a lavalized
ready master mix that they can have in
place
or have ready to go
to use with their with their in-house
reagents we've had customers that really
just want to convert their
in-house qpcr to a one-step using the
sativa aic mix and we've had success
with both
so we offer the sativa aic mix
alone if you wanted to purchase it that
way we offer our
rtq pcr master mix and reconstitution
buffer
separately as well if you wanted to
really just get into a lavalized
rtq pcr the keep in mind the rtq pcr
master mix does not include any primers
or probes but all the other necessary
ingredients are
that are required for amplification to
amplification of the target rna during
the detection step
are in there so really you just need to
add your primers and probes and you're
good to go
back to the full kit itself the full
direct kit
wilkin does contain the aic mix as well
as the sativa rtq pcr kit
and those are all broken down if you
have any further questions
please do not hesitate to email me or
give me a call
as we're winding down we i really wanted
to point out to some of the
products that have been supporting the
kova 19 efforts
and diagnostics using rt pcr
just wanted to remind you sativa as a
whole we are
very into a variety of different aspects
of the lab
sample preparation rna isolation whether
you want to develop your own kit
whether you want to use kind of some of
ours i think i mentioned the
extractor viral pathogen kit above
if you want to make your own kit from
your own magnetic bead
formulations we offer magnetic beads as
well carboxyl and silica beads
we also offer some oligo dt beads we do
poly a
we offer plates spin columns we do offer
detection detection consumables as well
so if you wanted
some nucleotides you need to attack
polymerase or sci-die
and then back into sequencing we have
different things that you can use if you
wanted to
test out for size selection or cleanup
we have our sour mag
select we do have t4 dna ligase if
you're really developing in pair
and like adapter ligation steps or if
you're
wanting to do some type of enrichment we
have ceramics or tavern and beads
then pcr again nucleotides we work with
kit developers we work with end users we
work with a wide range of
people lastly i want to mention
that we offer most of our products
have the capability to be customized and
that's really where our strength lies so
we can customize
many of our products many of your
in-house products so if you wanted to
make something lyle stable
if you wanted to try out a particular
formulation
if you wanted to do some type of
contract manufacturing
if you wanted to conjugate weird things
on your
weird proteins on your beads or
something that you have thought of that
would be
worked out great or would work out great
please don't hesitate to give us a call
we can help in
all those aspects
lastly thanks so much labroots for
allowing me to be here for lab week
thank you everyone who's taking the time
to listen to my presentation
again my name is donald green if you
want to
have more information please reach out
to me at donaldgreendonald.green
saitiva.com or you can reach me at my
telephone number including
the presentation as well i hope you have
a great lab week
and enjoy thank you